joining me
right now live and in person
i have an incredible co-pilot she is the
brilliant writer and comedian
transforming late night tv as we know it
and you can watch her razor sharp
variety show z-way on show time which by
the way just got picked up for season
two take a look
i'm honored that you you're doing the
show but my question is why did you
agree to this do you know who i am
i don't have sledge's idea anymore
[Music]
someone who worked for you was
incredibly persistent
incredibly persistent to the point where
this just seemed easier so shout out to
the persistence of women of color really
please welcome one of my personal idols
z-way fumido
thank you thank you for having me
i have already gotten our picture taken
i asked her to join us in our brand new
digital hub to kick off um
you know what that is there's no better
way to establish honestly anything than
being with you your
your
your interview style is
is so unique and not only do i want to
ask you advice but when i watch the fran
lebowitz piece and the way that you
unveil people
um and take off their armor piece by
piece with a very well researched very
extremely unique approach
you know
you're
you are a good person like what's your
take on the fran leibowitz you know
interview i love the friendly with
interview i just think she's so honest
and vulnerable and fran has been
she has been interviewed for decades
right we've heard fran speak and to get
new perspectives from her in 2021 wow
i'm proud i just love your style all
right let's get into the news i want to
talk fashion yes new york city is still
buzzing after last week's met gala
it was fashion week of course
and um the thing we didn't know we
needed larry david turned out to be the
star of fashion week um when he showed
up to the stad spring show and did this
okay
z way
what is it that loud what what is it i
was actually at that show and what was
ironic is that there was a celebrity dog
next to me and a producer approached the
dog and said there's gonna be loud
noises and i think that you know maybe
other guests at the show clearly could
have benefited from that warning
so
could the dog take it because they
really do have the sensitive hearing you
know the dog was also carrying so but
ultimately it was a gorgeous show so
worth it all right well also larry's
been out and all about and spotted with
fashion
icon slash actor icon slash every girl's
dream wish list it guy timothy chalamet
they've been hanging out and drinking
like espresso martinis by the way
timothy chalamet looks 10.
like he the baseball hat and the vest is
not doing his maturity any favors
what do you think z-way tell me
everything you were thinking of when you
look at this picture goo goo gaga i love
the range that we're getting i like an
intergenerational friendship i
personally look forward to having
friends who are you know
later in life and so i respect that
because it's like okay i'm from timothy
chalamet you can get advice about vests
from larry david you can get advice
about great prescriptions it's a great
it's a symbiotic relationship and i
think we need to honor and respect that
i love that okay z-way it's your story
okay so everyone is talking about the
hot new couple channing tatum and zoe
kravitz seen leaving the mat gala
together oh yeah true are you excited
about this new couple i feel like it
might be really one of the hottest
couples in in a long time um they
emanate heat like i can i feel like the
ozone layer is cracking because of
the the the ex what they're exposing
together when they get
into union they might be a danger to the
planet
this much chemistry might take us all
down i mean no but seriously like
i know what it would look like if i was
hanging out with someone it's like couch
delivery food tv
sweatpants hangout session yeah um
okay five okay
um
and i feel like they have a record
player and they're dirty dancing and
like there's like a pizza in the corner
on the floor with some candles around
and it's just like the hottest night
ever yes absolutely i wonder if channing
and zoe were actually friends first
before they became a couple well i do
happen to know that and this is
according to deadlines sort of our
industries you know
one of their more reliable sources that
she's actually directing a film
and he is attached to it so maybe
collaboration equals friendship equals
into relationship z-wave talk about your
next story because this does dovetail
well according to a new study that's how
most people prefer to start a
relationship as friends first well in
good reports that they surveyed over 2
000 adults and 66 said they were friends
with their partner before they got
together drew do you like the friends
before lovers approach
or does that cause some hazard
one time it caused real hazard
we were literally besties we traveled
the world together we got ready for
things together we were each others like
dates to things together
we poured our hearts out we dealt with
other relationships like within four
like to help each other we were at
besties for years and then one night
he looked at me different and i was like
what
and we
had that evening
and then the next time i saw him i of
course in my head i'm like oh we have
everything we're best friends we there's
nothing we can't do and now with this
new element we might be the ultimate
couple
and i showed up at our next thing and i
had that like
i wasn't looking at him the same way
anymore and he was like oh
and then i was like you had to ruin this
over a night this what and then i got
mad and then we didn't speak for years
wow
um and now we're still friends and both
married with kids and you know with
statue of limitations everybody sort of
just has to forgive their journey in
life um so i feel like both parties have
to clearly be on the same page about it
and um
how many people in the audience um
believe that friendship leads to a
relationship show of hands
okay
66 percent of people in the well and
good study said that they believe that
yeah what's your personal take on this
um
i don't have love of my life and i'm
actually really self-conscious about
that um i'm single i love it
okay
mine's like super by choice but um
or and by the way no one asked me out so
there's that too lives vibes but it's
hard you know it's hard don't approach
beautiful geniuses no i get it
do you get asked out no
we're packing a lot
we're all friends here that's what we do
on this show
[Music]
you